okay welcome back everybody okay so
today I'm going to finish talking about
the lorentz system and we're going to go
a little bit more into depth on what it
means for the system to be chaotic so
we're gonna get into this notion of
uncertainty in initial conditions and
chaos in in OD ease before we do that I
want to just briefly talk about the the
homework I think some of you have been
maybe struggling on a couple of these
problems making them a little bit more
difficult than I intended for them to be
so you'll notice that this homework
we're starting to kind of explore ideas
that were touched upon a little bit in
class but I really want you to go beyond
what I demonstrated in class so I'm just
gonna kind of start this example of
computing a matrix that does the
derivative of a vector F how many of you
are still working on this problem or
having some trouble with it how many of
you have this matrix and no know what
the answer is okay maybe I'll just go
really quickly because all of you seem
to have it right so so I've had a lot of
questions about whether or not we're
supposed to do this for like general
data or specific numbers in MATLAB like
are you supposed to code something up in
MATLAB and the answer is no I just want
kind of a by hand mathematical
expression for if you had these data
points F 1 F 2 F 3 F 4 I'm only going to
do four and you wanted to use those to
compute the derivatives you know at time
1/10 2/10 3/10 4 you can do that by
multiplying with a matrix okay so what
is based on our finite difference
derivative what is the forward
difference F 1 Prime
all right f2 minus f1 divided by Delta X
or Delta TIA is it a function of T or X
as a function of delta T so all you have
to do is find this row vector here just
has to reproduce this expression so I
have a 1 over delta T times f2 I have a
minus 1 over delta T times f1 and I have
0 f3 srf force ok pretty simple so that
will give you the first row for the
second and third and the middle rows you
do central difference and for the last
row you do a backward difference okay
that's all I'm asking for
so like no MATLAB code needed or
anything fancy are there any other big
questions on the homework yeah
and sorry exxon equals that matrix times
x apologize that's a typo yeah when
you're calling is the first part yeah
yes so for the last problem we're
simulating this Duffing the problem the
stuffing example with a bunch of
parameters i think it's like alpha beta
gamma Omega delta a right ton of
parameters so this is actually a lot
like the Lorentz system we did in class
where I'm gonna define a general
right-hand side vector field and then
I'm going to kind of lock into place
those parameters using OD 45 and
function handles you could hard code it
that would be like one way to do it but
it's a little less flexible okay good
so today we're going to talk more about
chaos in the lorentz system and then on
Monday we're going to talk about chaos
and more general physical systems like
mechanical linkages and astrophysics
problems in fluid dynamics so Monday
will be more of an applied lecture a
little less mathematical which is always
fun and this lecture we're gonna do
almost entirely MATLAB okay
okay so last time we had looked at the
lorentz system it's a third it's a it's
a system with three states and it's a
nonlinear system with quadratic
nonlinearities and it's the classical
model for chaos in atmosphere systems
okay so we all know that the climate is
kind of a chaotic dynamical system and
this is one of the first models that
exhibited that chaos and so what we
showed yesterday was how to create a
right-hand side vector field in MATLAB
dysfunction to many of these this
function in Lorentz okay so this is a
general right-hand side Y dot equals
Lorentz of Y would be my non-linear OTE
and this can take in parameter sigma
beta Rho that I can change that well
okay we also coded up our single delta t
time step fourth order runge-kutta
algorithm that we wrote down on the
board and the idea is that for any
function you can decide for any
right-hand function of a system of first
order OD es we can evaluate that
function at different points in time and
space and using this Runge Kutta
algorithm we can get a very accurate
prediction for the next States at the
next time step okay any questions about
the the first two now that you've had
some time to think about them and things
to set in so for example you could use
this RK for single step for your Duffing
oscillator problem right you could you
could write a function like my Lorentz
dot n but you could call it Duffing got
N and you could call Runge Kutta for
single step of your Duffing oscillator
okay but this function has to be a
function of just time and space so if
you have additional parameters like
Alpha Beta Gamma Delta then you're going
to have to create a function of T comma
Y using the function handles so that
symbol how many of you feel
comfortable with the @ symbol function
handles but anyone like like one more
example of how to do this yeah T of you
okay okay so let's see if I can do this
so Lorentz is a function of five
variables right I give it a time x 0
some states like 1 1 1 and then Sigma
Beta Rho okay and if I give it all five
numbers it spits out the Lorentz vector
field at those parameters and points of
time and space okay but I could say my
let's call it like new Lorentz equals a
function of T and Y only okay so that's
what this at T comma Y means this is I'm
defining on the fly a function of just T
and Y ok and that function is going to
be my original Lorentz function of T and
Y but I'm gonna lock into place Sigma
Theta and Rho okay so this is the syntax
I can take a function of multiple I can
take a function of multiple variables
like Lorentz and I can lock in some of
those variables with real numbers or
vectors or whatever they take and I can
thus create a function of just T and Y
so this is a wrapper
okay we're wrapping the function Lorentz
we're fixing a few of its parameters and
we're getting out a function new Lorentz
which is just a function of T and Y okay
so new Lorentz I could use directly with
my RK for single step or my OD 45
because those expect functions just of T
comma Y okay
with this at symbol you can create
functions on the fly really easily I
could say my quadratic equals at X X dot
squared and if I say my quadratic of two
it should give me four okay so these
function handles are really flexible
they allow you to like in line to find a
function you can wrap a function in
by locking in parameter values and
recasting it as a you know different
inputs and so that's what we're doing
here in the Duffing example in the
homework and then in the slow rents
example we have these two variables
which are actually going to be changing
like time and space those you know why
is my position that's getting integrated
and then Sigma Beta Rho we're gonna lock
into place for different examples okay
good so we have Lorentz we have our k
for single step which takes in a
function of just T and Y and then we
have this simulate Lorentz function
where we have this big for loop and for
every DT we step our state forward using
this wrapped function we just we just
wrote this is like my new Lorentz
function okay so this is just a rehash
of what we did last time and when you
simulate this and compare against lost
my cursor this is gonna be impossible
okay so when you compare that solution
with OD 45 you say okay RK 4 single step
versus ode45 we find that they actually
agree very very well for a little while
but then they start to disagree at the
end of the trajectory at the end of the
time interval these trajectories are
actually separating okay so have I
already explained what like some of the
formal definitions of chaos might be no
okay this is a good time to do it so
probably the most practical and formal
definition of chaos this is going to be
really practically useful for everyone
is a system is chaotic if its solutions
have a very sensitive dependence on the
initial condition so you probably heard
this before sensitive dependence on
initial condition what that means is if
I have some initial condition
and I perturb it even very slightly like
0.000001 difference in the initial
condition after some time you know
they'll agree for a little while but
then after some time those two solutions
will go to very different places meaning
I have a lot of sensitivity a lot of
change due to a very very small change
in initial condition that's the hallmark
of chaos if a system has that it is
chaotic if it doesn't it's not okay
that's mostly true so let's do an
example of this let's take our so this
is a little dangerous I've never done
this demo but I decided five minutes ago
that I want to show you what this
actually means so we have Lawrence's
parameters we have our initial condition
and I'm going to define an epsilon as
0.001 times one's three comma one
okay so my epsilon is a perturbation to
my initial condition and it's point
ooo one times the column vector of three
ones so I'm going to simulate the system
with just Y and then I'm also going to
simulate the system with Y naught plus
Epsilon so I'm gonna have two initial
conditions very close to each other
we're gonna start them off and we're
gonna see where they go okay maybe I'm
gonna make this point
0:01 cuz I've never done this demo
before and I don't know how sensitive it
really is test sensitivity okay so I
wanted to show you how our K for single
step works how you would actually code
this up but for all you know for now I'm
going to use OD 45 okay
so I have this solution OD 45 for this
initial condition why not okay so if I
run this code it's going to generate one
trajectory this red trajectory starting
at Y knots and doing its thing now I can
take this exact same OD 45 code say hold
on and instead of giving it an initial
condition Y naught I'm gonna give it Y
naught plus Epsilon
all right small perturbation to my
initial condition we're gonna see where
that trajectory goes and then I'm going
to plot the same stuff but in blue and
now my legend says y naught plus Epsilon
so if this works okay interesting so
it's almost exactly the same as the
other example we showed right they start
very very close together they agree for
a long time but then towards the end of
this trajectory you can see that the
blue and the red curves are starting to
separate right let's run this for just a
tad longer so instead of the time zero
to four let's do like zero to five
see if I can make this bigger it's a
little hard to see now maybe zero to ten
and let's make this bolder
okay
so at the end of this this simulation
now the red and the blue curves are like
eventually going to very very different
places right they're gonna go to
completely different sides of this
butterfly attractor now and for all
intents and purposes they're completely
different different trajectories even
though they started very close to each
other if I wanted to quantify how
different their trajectories have become
what could I do
yeah yeah let's plot one minus the other
that's a good idea okay it's a little
tricky because we have a three vector
right so if I plot just the first column
of y1 it looks like this okay that's my
first component of this trajectory my
second component also looks like that
and my third component is just
oscillating so how am I going to compare
all three of these in time I'm going to
call its whites you
okay so how if I have these like these
every point in this is a three vector
how do I compare all these three vectors
yeah I think so yeah so I can I can just
compute like the l2 norm the Euclidean
distance between these these three
vectors for every point in time okay so
let's make sure we do this right size of
Y is a thousand and one by three so I'm
gonna say for I equals one to a thousand
and one diff of I equals norm of Y to I
colon minus y I : I think okay so four
so a thousand and one time points and
for every time point I have three you
know values XY and Z so what I'm going
to do is for every single time point I'm
going to evaluate how close those
trajectories are at that point in time
which is the norm of that set of
positions at that time minus the other
set of positions at that time for the
two trajectories so norm is just a nice
command that computes the square root of
the sum of the squares of X square plus
y squared plus Z squared
okay compute the distance so if this
works and now let's create a new figure
and we're going to plot the DIF
interesting
okay so this isn't exactly what I was
expecting that's the fun of doing live
demos is this is what the difference
looks like in time okay so for awhile
they start off agreeing very very
closely but then pretty quickly you
actually get huge disagreements and what
are these big spikes correspond to do
you think anyone yeah right there are
different sides of this butterfly
attractor so like at this point kind of
after time you know 500 time steps these
things are completely on different
trajectories on the butterfly sometimes
they get close to each other but then
they're completely you know going to
different different sides of this
attractor so that's what we're seeing
here this is like full chaos has set in
at this point but let's zoom in down
here where they actually agree pretty
well okay see if this works at all
so at the very very very very onset of
this initial condition perturbation what
we have actually looks a lot like
exponential growth okay so this is
another hallmark of chaos is that if you
you know when you see two trajectories
that start really close to each other in
fact why don't we make this more
exaggerated by making our epsilon much
smaller okay we're going to start with a
smaller perturbation so that they stay
closer for longer we're gonna plot the
same thing and now notice they agree for
a lot longer right
if i zoom in and zoom in zoom in
actually looks basically the same that's
interesting but basically you have this
kind of exponential divergence of these
two trajectories so that little epsilon
is getting multiplied by e to some
lambda T in time and they're getting
farther and farther and farther apart
okay so that's the other hallmark of
chaos this kind of quantifies what this
what we mean by set by high-sensitivity
it means that we have exponential
divergence of these two trajectories at
early time okay and that this would be
true for any point that I selected for
any initial condition that I chose I
would get in exponential divergence of
these initial conditions okay so are
there questions at this point we're
gonna kind of code up a more
sophisticated example but I just want to
like answer questions right now
so what are some examples of systems
that are a little bit less mathematical
that have the sensitivity to initial
conditions so fluid flow is sometimes
chaotic in fact you can break fluid flow
into two broad categories those that are
chaotic and those that are not chaotic
and usually in fluids we call that
laminar and turbulent
okay so turbulence is fundamentally a
chaotic phenomenon if you had a
turbulent flow and you dropped a little
bubble or you know piece of dye and if
you move that some tiny tiny epsilon
those dyes would go to completely
different places very very quickly and
they would diverge exponentially quickly
at first okay so so fluid flows that are
turbulent are chaotic what are some
other examples
gravity planetary movements of gravity
are chaotic in some places yeah they're
they're all chaotic for really long
times so we can't predict where all of
the planets will be very accurately for
an arbitrarily long time horizon in fact
one of the most powerful computers in
the world at least a decade ago was
called the ephemeris like it was a
computer that solved the simulation
called the ephemeris which essentially
tracked every planetary body that we
knew about all of the planets and the
moons and the space junk and the big
comets and all of the stuff that we knew
about and because these objects are
really massive and really slow the chaos
this exponential diversion of
trajectories might take 10,000 years but
in 10,000 years it's very very hard to
know where everything will be because
all of these trajectories are kind of
asymptotically diverging from each other
based on our uncertainty of how close we
know the initial conditions and the
masses okay so this is another point I
really want to make is that in any
engineering system we only know the
parameters of the model and the initial
conditions to some finite precision
right look you can only machine
something to some real finite precision
you can only measure the initial
condition of a planet into some finite
precision and so there's a fundamental
uncertainty there's a fundamental kind
of ball of uncertainty in every initial
condition and every differential
equation that you ever write down okay
and so that's why chaos is such a nasty
problem is that it gets you know that
uncertainty in your initial state of
your system gets magnified and stretched
and becomes a bigger and bigger problem
farther and farther in time okay
so there's a whole field called
uncertainty quantification that has
cropped up to address this problem and
it's huge in mechanical engineering like
really uncertainty quantification has
been borne out of mechanical engineering
where you have finite precision
measurements and initial conditions and
manufactured things
what are some other examples any other
ones so climate is super chaotic
yeah weather is very chaotic if weather
was not chaotic then we would know what
the weather would be three months from
now but it's not so we can only tell
what the weather is gonna be for a few
days and there's actually uncertainty on
those measurements like they get it
right maybe seventy or eighty percent of
the time but there's always uncertainty
because we just can't predict there's
too much chaos and we don't have good
enough initial conditions and it moves
quickly okay that's enough examples for
now there's a lot more many many many
many systems are chaotic but lots aren't
one of the first examples of chaos was
this experiment by a guy named Phil
Holmes who is actually visiting the
applied math department at u-dub right
now he's one of the greatest kind of OD
II people still alive today and he built
an experiment with another guy named
moon where they took a steel beam where
you could like strike the beam and you
have some elastic equation maybe it's
like a linear or if you hit it hard
enough you get some nonlinear elastic
deformations and what they did was they
put two big magnets on either side of it
and now when you strike this thing when
it gets close to one magnet it starts
feeling a different set of forces and
then it moves back and forth because it
has you know it's equations of elastic
motion and they actually find that this
system very very simple system is
extremely chaotic you can't predict at
all like what the motion of this beam
will do when you put those two magnets
next to it so this was before this
experiments that was extremely well
measured people thought that chaos meant
you built a shitty experiment they
thought that if you couldn't predict
where your solution was going to go it's
because you built in some bad
uncertainty or you messed up your
calculations or your experimental
measurements aren't good enough but they
show that these are you know or nearly
exact experimental measurements
the system still had this chaotic
behavior okay so for a long time there
was dispute about whether or not chaos
was even real between practice and
engineers and mathematicians and so Phil
Holmes who's visiting the applied math
department was one of the first people
that definitively shut down the
naysayers and actually proved that chaos
was a real a real thing in physical
systems so you should meet Phil Holmes
he's a great guy
he works on insect locomotion now he can
tell you why cockroaches run even when
their legs get ripped off or if you put
it they actually put jetpacks on
cockroaches there's such good runners
they're so robust that you can mount a
little rocket rocket pack to the back of
a cockroach while they're running away
from something and you turn this jet on
and they veer over but within maybe five
or six steps they actually recorrect and
get back on track to where they were
going like incredibly robust animals and
Phil Holmes is one of the world's
experts on on insect locomotion okay so
something I want to do here is there's
two things I want to do I want to really
get to the bottom of this idea of
uncertainty in initial conditions okay
and so what we're going to do is instead
of simulating one point through this
system I'm going to create a grid of a
bunch of points really tightly together
and we're gonna simulate all of them and
follow the trajectory of this group of
nearby particles okay
and I also so instead of integrating one
point we're integrating like a volume of
points and the other thing I wanted to
do is illustrate why some codes in
MATLAB are really really slow and how
you can make them faster okay so a lot
of you are going to use MATLAB for
research which is great it's what I use
for research you can prototype things
it's really easy to simulate and
visualize and do numerical experiments
but MATLAB can be terribly slow how many
of you think you know why MATLAB is
terribly slow
why isn't that loud terribly slow okay
what does that mean right and every time
you write a for loop it actually
essentially compiles that code locally
in time to execute it on your computer
okay so there's a difference between
codes that are compiled ahead of time
like C and C++ and Fortran and
interpreted languages that run kind of
as the code is running it's being
compiled like MATLAB and Python and
interpreted languages interpreted
languages are usually much much slower
but also much easier to work with in
real time for a human okay so those are
the trade-offs so I'm going to show you
the bad kind of the naive way of doing
this volume of particle simulation and
then I'm going to show you the super
fast way to do it okay okay so I'm gonna
clear all I'm gonna save this and I'm
gonna call it sim Lorentz slow okay this
is kind of a naive this is the first
thing you would do but this is the naive
way to solve the problem okay I'm going
to copy over some of my parameters from
before
okay
okay so I'm still going to have
Lawrence's parameters but instead of
this initial condition what I'm going to
do is I'm going to create a grid of
initial conditions I'm going to
integrate all of them through the system
so initial condition one is going to be
a large cube of data so Y naught is
going to start at 0 0 0 okay so how many
of you know how to get a big mesh of
particles any commands that do this
really really easily okay good so
there's a really useful command that all
of you are gonna love now called mesh
grid okay so you create an X vector
let's say 4 minus 20 in increments of 2
to 20 and I'm going to do the same thing
with a Y vector and a Z vector and then
what I can say is X naught Y naught Z
naught equals mesh grid of X vector Y
vector Z vector ok and what this does is
I tell I'm essentially telling MATLAB
that I want a cube of data given with
like with resolution in the x-direction
given by the expectation in the
y-direction given by Y vector and with
resolution in the Z Direction given by Z
vector so if I run this now I can say
what is the size of X naught and it's a
big 21 by 21 by 21 cube of expositions
ok sighs why not is a big 21 by 21 by 21
cube of Y positions and Z knots the same
thing if actually type X knots you see
that it's this big like these are all
the expositions in order in this cube of
expositions
okay so I can construct a for loop for I
for j4k and I could count through every
single position in this cube and get the
x y&z positions for everything in this
cube from minus 20 to 20
okay good so now we're going to say okay
so I'm going to create this new data
structure of initial conditions it's
going to be this big four dimensional
monster why I see 1 : : : equals x not
why I see 2 : : : equals y knots and why
I see 3 : : : equals Z not notice I have
to give it 3 colons because X naught is
a 3-dimensional array so that's the only
way that it could possibly fit in here
okay
now let's plot why I see one why I see -
why I see 3 and red dots with line width
2 and marker size 4 axis so I'm going
through all of these details because I
want you to also know how to visualize
data ok so like you're gonna be able to
have all of these codes and now you're
going to know how I make plots of data
[ __ ] okay plots three okay
so this is my initial cube of data I
changed the view like view as a command
that allows you to rotate your camera
view so you can see it from different
angles so that's my initial cube of data
kind of cool
so access and view and draw now are just
things that make it look nice on the
screen so those are kind of
non-technical ok so now we're going to
compute our trajectory we're gonna make
a dt of 0.01 a duration of 4 a timespan
from zero to duration and the amount of
time points we're gonna have is duration
divided by DT and my particles are why I
see okay so now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna step for all of the time
steps we're gonna take this cube of
particles and we're going to advance it
1 DT forward ok ok so for our time step
equals 1/2 L the number of time steps
okay so to advance this entire cube of
data I'm gonna have to write this nested
for loop for I equals 1/2 block for J
equals 1/2 block for K equals 1/2 block
I'm gonna have to step through all of
the positions in this cube and step each
of them forward 1 DT okay because my RK
for single step and ode45 only knows how
to handle one trajectory at a time ok so
my time equals step times DT for I
equals 1 to the length of my X vector
for J equals 1 to the length of my Y
vector and for K equals 1 to the length
of my Z vector I'm going to say
my why in is why particles : i JK then
I'm going to step these particles
forward one DT and I'm going to save
them to my trajectory okay so I'm gonna
do my RK 4 single step of my Lorenz
function on that particular so for this
particular I J and K I pull that
position at that current time and that's
my that's my position and I'm gonna step
it one DT forward okay so Lorentz T
comma Y comma Sigma Beta Rho DT time Y
in and Y particles : i j k equals y out
and and and okay and then for every
single one of these time steps i'm going
to plot my new particles okay so i'm
going to do the same plot three command
y particles 1 : y particles 2 : y
particles 3 : in red dots with the same
language and all of this stuff in the
same position and axis and all that
okay so if I run this this is a long
code I'm not expecting this to make
total sense right now but when we run
this we're stepping for every DT we're
going from every single little point in
this cube of data and we're stepping
them all forward one DT and then we plot
them and then we do it again and again
and again okay let's hope this works
okay so we're starting to see the effect
of all of these particles as they
advance through my Lorenz attractor okay
so the simulation has gotten faster
since the first time I wrote it because
my computer is much faster but it's
still painfully slow to watch I really
want to know where these particles are
going and they're not moving there fast
enough for me okay okay so are there any
ideas for how we can make this much much
faster
has anyone tried making a MATLAB code
way faster like this yeah what do you do
okay so there's this notion of taking my
nested for-loops and turning this into a
vectored operation a vectorized
operation so what that means is so I
told you MATLAB is interpreted which
means that it kind of reads every line
and interprets it as it's going but it's
built on top of really powerful compiled
codes that were written in Fortran
decades ago okay
so matrix multiplication is SuperDuper
fast in MATLAB because it's calling a
compiled code to do matrix
multiplication taking a singular value
decomposition or matrix factorization or
like multiplying two matrices is way way
fast so if we can find some way of
taking that cube of data and integrating
them all delta-t at the same time using
matrix operations this should be
hundreds and hundreds of times faster
okay so in general vectorizing will make
this way way faster let me see how
complicated this code is to do this okay
I think we can do this
okay so what I'm gonna do is create a
code called Lorentz 3d it's gonna be
basically the exact same as my right
hand side Lorentz except it's going to
evaluate this DUI not for a single
particle but for a whole 3-dimensional
array of particles it's gonna look
really weird there's gonna be a lot of
colons this is a big arrayed monster dy
equals okay Sigma times y2 this is going
to look basically the same as our
original Lorentz except instead of the
second position of Y it's going to be Y
2 comma colon colon colon it's going to
be the second position of Y for all of
the I J and K values in that volume so
that's what : : : means is for all of
those three dimensions of my array of
particles I want the second state to the
Y state okay - y1 : : :
y1 : : : dot times row minus y of 3 : :
: this is not that interesting but if I
can type fast enough you'll see a pretty
cool simulation okay
okay all I did was just modify my
Lorentz code and any time I saw a y1 y2
y3 I just put three colons in front of
it because I want to integrate a
three-dimensional a 3-dimensional array
of points so you can imagine putting an
AIA J and a K in here and you get to put
a Y position for that ijk so you're
probably going to want to look at this
you know after class okay so the same
code except now we're going to call this
sim Lorentz fast we have our Sigma beta
Rho we have our initial conditions and
now to compute the trajectory let's see
if I can do this for step equals 1 to L
we have time equals step we're gonna say
y out equals R K for single step at T
why Lorentz 3d of tu I Sigma Beta Rho DT
time y n okay so this R K for single
step didn't change at all except now
instead of giving it just a single
position for one of those points in my
volume I'm giving it this huge four
dimensional array of all the points in
my volume
okay and I can get rid of this horrible
nested for loop and if I didn't make a
typo which is a little worried this will
run all right let's try one more this
should be why ouch not why particles
okay that's good it didn't complain in
the middle so this will actually run a
lot faster if I remember to suppress my
output this should have been more
impressive okay where is my output okay
there we go so notice the difference
between the fast vectorized version and
the really crummy for loop version okay
so this was worth all of the the boring
typing nonsense
so we can do some neat experiments now
that this is fast before we do these
experiments are there questions so this
was like way too fast to really follow
the details of what I did in MATLAB I
want you to go back and look at this
because you are going to be wanting to
vectorize and make your cuts fast and
you should see what I did the bottom
line is the built-in function OD 45 does
not handle multiple initial conditions
well neither does our original RK 4
single step so what we had to do is
modify actually our RK 4 single step
does handle vectors well and so we
modified our right hand side so that it
can evaluate the right-hand side for
thousands of particles all at once and
create this massive four dimensional
array of right hand side D wise okay and
then we can we can write this in a
massively vectorized way okay questions
about this before we start digging a
little deeper into the chaos yeah
doesn't probably handle the vectors will
is there a function that's already in
MATLAB it does you might be able to
manipulate OD 45 to do something similar
to what we did but I haven't been
successful doing that in the past and
it's easier for me to just write my own
RK 4 so if I want to do a big so MATLAB
for OD 45 also takes variable time steps
so it has kind of an internal error
checker so that if it thinks that it's
error is getting too large for every
little DT it will cut DT in half or if
it thinks that it's able to it'll double
its DT and go faster and that doesn't
work well with lots and lots of
particles because they each need their
own DT and so OD 45 variable time step
doesn't work for multiple trajectories
so the RK for single step that we wrote
is a fixed time step rugged Kutta
algorithm which is better suited for
like running lots of trajectories
through simultaneously you might be able
to trick OD 45 into doing it but this is
like pretty pretty straightforward ok so
I think I'd rather show you some of the
neat things now that we have this fast
code in the next lecture what we're
gonna start doing notice I started with
a huge volume of initial conditions over
a really large range and they kind of
spread out and fill this entire
butterfly attractor so what we're gonna
do next time is we're gonna pick a
single initial condition and we're gonna
create a really really tight cube of
initial conditions around it and see how
they stretch and fold with the chaos but
I don't think we have time now so we'll
do that on Monday and I'll bring another
physical demo like an actual physical
experiment that exhibits chaos okay all
right let's all have a nice weekend
you